hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
where i react to pretty much whatever
the comments or my instagram dms
recommend to me so if you want to be a
part of that dm me on instagram or
comment below but today i am reacting to
a video titled the eye-opening secrets
girls don't want you to know by the
fresh and fit
podcast i'm a girl i want to know what
secrets
do i want not want guys to know because
i can't think of one don't forget to
subscribe
as usual trying to move out of my
parents house
you guys already know the drill okay the
eye-opening secrets and i'm excited
because this video is only like six
minutes as opposed to like 12.
oh no these are usually like three hours
i'm gonna just stop talking
[Music]
i need to get intro music what kind of
intro music should i get oh my gosh
no i was just saying that in general you
know the women they tell me everything
so
any type of specific story listen girls
trips
man i'm talking about i'm talking about
i'm talking about marriages boyfriends
all that getting ran trains on
just meeting because they know it's like
um how do i say
they think that oh they'll never see
them again yeah they're popular but not
so popular where they'll be recognized
they can just go get it in oh man yeah
that's
if your girl says i want to go to vegas
or miami on a girls trip bro she belongs
to the streets i cannot tell you how
many girls come to miami to have fun
you know this whole time right yeah they
will set up with on instagram like 10
guys like
one has a boat party one has a after
party they have a whole itinerary yeah
for sure
and you're the guy for that day and then
oh you know what my friends want to go
here so sorry i'll see you next
time and you know what because we'll
talk we get a lot of haters myron
fresh just because you guys deal with
these girls in miami doesn't mean that
all the girls are like that bro that all
women are like that you guys are some
angry massages
well you know what bro girls come here
from other states to party and have a
good time
these girls that you say are the girl
next door she's not like that
they go on vacation to come here to let
loose and be on boats with [ __ ] like
us bro
that's why we're telling you guys is
because we see it first hand here in
miami florida
go live in a vacation destination on
miami vegas uh l.a or new york city
i hate
guy okay there are girls like that i'm
not saying there aren't girls like that
but like
like the majora i'm not gonna say none
of like the girls that i've had as
friends
have cheated on their boyfriends like
that would be a lie that's definitely
happened
but the majority of the friends that i
have
and that i've gone on girls trips on
like
it it really was not like that like we
were not
it was not crazy like that where
hypergamy is always on steroids and the
girls are
basically taking the guys to the top
bidder you'll see what i'm talking about
bro
girls go on girl trips for a reason not
to mention there's statistical proof out
there
that women travel alone far more than
men do
since the advent of the internet if you
look at lone travelers it's way more
women than men guys
why ask yourself what is why do we
travel alone
bruh because women know when they leave
their immediate geographic area and
they're able to travel
they're able to do things they otherwise
would never do sexually and be able to
get away with it you know
that's true that's like
i i've definitely seen like friends do
things like that
but they were single like none of them
had boyfriend like seriously the
majority of my friends do not cheat
would not cheat
i'm saying the french girl yep traveled
here by yourself
exactly and i'm like yo a hugger like
this why are you traveling alone
yo bruh chick stop all the time you know
that night
i was super lit we were out and about
out doing some nice stuff with my boy
yeah and uh yeah that was that the girl
in the
that i saw yeah yeah yeah yeah her yeah
yeah i saw this dude i was oh okay cool
here's the thing bro like i'm telling
you guys like women travel alone a lot
more
nowadays because here's the thing
there's two ways that women typically
travel guys i'm about to put you guys on
some game right now okay
yeah there's a school bell right
so they either a preferably they travel
alone if they have the guts to do it
they travel alone because then they're
able to do what they want without no
type of headaches
because the problem with girls trips
guys is that nine out of 10 times
especially if it's a big group of girls
there's going to be one or two prudes in
the group that are going to ruin it for
other girls that want to get lit
right so a lot of girls will go on girls
trips like bachelor this is what i tell
guys don't hit on bachelorette parties
because
especially if it's big there might be
two or three girls four girls in the
group that are about it but then there's
going to be other girls in there that
are approved maybe have a boyfriend at
home maybe married whatever it may be
and those girls are going to buzz kill
yeah and that's what i'm saying
like all girls aren't like that
there are some there are some girls some
of my friends i would not recommend
got my like guy friends to date but like
that's just not
that's just not true all the time i
should say and they're gonna judge and
talk smack and guys
women are not like us they care a lot
about what their friends think
so if a girl is out with her friends
right on a girl's trip out
and you meet her at a club and she's
feeling you right and you're trying to
pull her and then her friends pull her
away
she's always gonna go with her
girlfriends and the reason why guys is
because women aren't like us where
if let's say me largely and fresh are at
the club right and i meet a bad chick
all right guys i'm leaving with her
ain't nobody got okay they're like
alright bro see you later later
that's why it's really important to
surround yourself with a good group of
friends
because you you become like who you're
surrounded
with girls they're going to talk smack
about her and she doesn't want to deal
with that crap
when they go to brunch tomorrow at you
know in south beach wherever they have
playing because girls have an itinerary
when they get here
so if a girl misses a part of that
itinerary especially gonna deal with a
random dude
they're gonna shame her the entire trip
yep so what happens is a lot of girls
that started traveling alone to mitigate
that problem and they tell me themselves
yeah i travel alone because i mean
girls are annoying whatever hell i've
met so many girls that say yo i don't
like being friends with girls because
it's annoying they're judgmental there's
i would say more girls travel with like
one person you're not trying to like
i've never gone to like a bar
by myself unless i go there for karaoke
i do
i do kill karaoke a bunch of passive
aggressive stuff i'd rather be friends
with guys
which we talk about all the time why
women really like to be friends with
guys yeah they get all the benefits of a
boyfriend without actually giving bucks
and they don't get judged for doing the
stupid stuff that they do there's
another reason too
for girls going out with her gay guy
friends traveling bruh
danger zone for real like bro the girl
has uh you know
happy friends if you know what i'm
saying they enable all situations
they're going to enable
all bad situations bro yeah so that's
another purpose another piece of game
for you guys if you're at a club and you
see a girl
with um happy guys bro go approach
go talk to the happy guys hey man i
think she's kind of cute are you calling
me talking to her
bro they'll open it they'll and you're
not like a weirdo when you're cool jesse
can set it up for you
talk to him he's so high yeah that's
good advice
i mean i don't have
gay friends like i'm not against it i
just don't have like
i was never that girl to have like a lot
of them but i could see that going well
just like from like
the friends that i do have they'll do it
and a lot of guys won't
would it think to do that but that's
actually a really good move because you
build rapport with him
that's the authority on the trip a lot
of times even though he's a happy guy
that girl is going to respect his
decision yeah so and
more importantly he's going to enable
you right if you're not a weirdo whereas
like some like annoying
mother hen is gonna ruin it for you so
just understand guys that when um
women have a lot of options and when
they travel they're gonna enact on those
options especially if they travel alone
sorry do you have something
i was just gonna say that i
hate when they talk in generalities
because that's not like
real life and if you just like live your
life like
where you expect every rich guy to cheat
every hot girl to cheat
it's like a really negative way to look
at the world and i know and it sucks
because there's no way to like prove
otherwise
right because if i say oh that's not how
a lot of my friends are that are really
attractive like that's
not necessarily true people will always
just comment
well you just don't know about it it
could be true
but like there's no way to really prove
it honestly or if there is let me know
in the comments
a cheat code to all of that is having
game
literally that's a cheat code like yeah
um there were times
back in the past when i had no money um
like
you know just a regular dude or whatever
the case is but because you know i
approached him in a certain way i had
game or whatever i was still able to
you know knock him down and that's it
yeah i was able to get it and i want to
say one more point to the point we were
talking about before about the girls
traveling and
uh messing with our higher status dudes
and stuff yo
this please guys this is really really
really important
if you are if you do catch um if it's
your turn and you do catch an eight nine
or ten
strap up with her i'm telling you that
right now strap up because when
she's messing with these football uh
football players nfl
wrong yeah always always always
at least ninety percent of the time
exactly bro they got so bad that
that you know i
i've never talked to a professional
athlete
none of my friends have i don't know
anything about that life nba had to put
out guys there was a controversial email
sent out a couple of years ago
uh from the nba to all the players
saying yo when you
have fun with these bedroom fun with
these girls make sure you wrap up and
throw the
condominium in the toilet and flush it
they had to tell their own players to do
this guys so what does that tell you
these dudes are running around like you
know with no snake skin if you know what
i'm saying you know
they're going raw in there so just
understand if girls deal with athletes
bro protect yourselves
bro damn um
i'm sure that in
like the life that they're like involved
in everything that they said is
true and like the fat like the fast life
i'm sure that's true but
there are genuinely people that aren't
into partying and aren't into that stuff
so i don't know maybe go for them but
let me know in the comments what you
guys think don't forget to like comment
and subscribe especially subscribe
please
bye